[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions--
PAUL KINLAN: Hi everyone.
I'm Paul Kinlan, and welcome to
our fourth installment of
the Chrome Apps weekly
roundup of all
things latest and greatest.
This week is about file
storage APIs.
We are actually missing the most
important person at the
Hangout at the moment.
PAUL LEWIS: We are?
PAUL KINLAN: So he'll be
here soon, we hope.
But anyway, I'd like to
introduce myself.
I'm Paul Kinlan.
I'm a developer advocate at
Google, and I'm working on the
Chrome Apps project to kind
of help to get developers
interested, excited, and learn
more about the platform that
we're building to Chrome.
And I would like to introduce
Paul Lewis.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, as you
said, I'm Paul Lewis.
I'm a developer programs
engineer here at Google.
I'm also on the Chrome Apps
team, and I write tutorial
samples, and help the developers
build their apps.
PAUL KINLAN: Generally kick
ass web [INAUDIBLE] stuff.
PAUL LEWIS: That's
also what I do.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: Or what
I try to do.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, it's
kind of cool.
As you can tell, we're both
English, but we're
broadcasting from
Mountain View.
So it's kind of weird.
We're all in weird time zones.
It's crazy.
And on our Hangout--
I hope we can speak to them OK,
but on our Hangout, we've
got Renato.
RENATO MANGINI: Hello.
I am Renato Mangini.
I am speaking from Brazil, and
I also am a Chrome developer,
engineer, for the Developer
Relations Team.
Yeah, and that's cool.
PAUL KINLAN: All right.
Awesome.
Cool.
So We are waiting for one more
person, Eric Bidelman.
He's our developer relations
guru for file system API.
I believe he has a book
as well, about
the file system API.
PAUL LEWIS: No doubt he will
tell us all about that.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, with his
Amazon referral code in.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Anyway,
yes he has a book.
We're waiting for him.
He should be here pretty soon.
And he's going to show you
some really cool stuff.
But before we do that, I'd just
like to kind of pass it
over to Renato to actually talk
about some of the changes
that have happened in the
platform this week.
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah.
Thank you, Paul.
The last two weeks we have
one very big change
on the window object.
Before, you used methods to
control the window using the
Window API, like focus, and
minimize, maximize, and other
controlling methods.
And you used these methods
on the same window object
you are using to--
that exposed the DOM to
your JavaScript code.
However, this week, we landed
a change that there's a
wrapper around the DOM, and this
wrapper contains other
Window APIs.
And you can access the same old
DOM object as before using
the child.dom object property
on the window.
PAUL LEWIS: So you're not--
RENATO MANGINI: So
now you have to--
sorry.
Go ahead.
PAUL LEWIS: I was going to ask
you a question about it.
So if before you were getting
a reference to a window and
you were calling Create Element
on the document inside
that window or something
like that, now you have
to go via this DOM--
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah,
child.dom.
Before, you called the focus,
for example, and the Create
Element at the same object.
And now you have--
the DOM element is the same DOM
window you are used to,
but this object is
a property of a
high-level app window object.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
So what--
RENATO MANGINI: And this app
window object contains all the
specific methods for
the window API.
PAUL KINLAN: OK, so that gives
us the ability to, say,
minimize or maximize and
those types of things.
Are there very specific
window APIs opposed
to DOM-level APIs?
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah, exactly.
He can get this app window
high-level object using the
current methods.
You just call
chrome.app.window.current
method, and you get
the reference for
this app window object.
And you also get this
reference--
when you create a window, you
get this reference back, so
you can use it or
you can access
directly using the current.
PAUL KINLAN: So if there's even
anyone who's built any
applications which use to post
a message to communicate
between windows, which I think
one of the folks up here with
demos does.
I'm assuming we're going to
have to change the code to
actually just map that,
but it shouldn't be
too much of a change.
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah.
Instead of accessing the window
object returned by
Create to make changes on the
DOM, objectively, you have to
pass the child.dom instead
of the window itself.
PAUL LEWIS: Cool.
Awesome.
RENATO MANGINI: OK.
And the second change is the
Media Gallery's .get media
file system is no longer
experimental.
And you have to have specific
permission for
Media Gallery's read.
We didn't mention Media
Galleries yet here, but we'll
have a session in the future
to talk about that.
But if you have already
developed something using the
Media Galleries, just be warned
that now it's not
experimental anymore.
PAUL KINLAN: Can you explain
briefly about the Media
Gallery PIS?
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah.
When you call the GET media file
systems, you get access
to all the file systems that
contain media, photos, videos,
and et cetera.
For example, if you plug in a
camera or a USB drive, you can
access these objects in a kind
of sandbox of file system that
you only have read
permissions.
PAUL LEWIS: Good news, folks.
We have Eric Bidelman.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Hey.
PAUL KINLAN: He's here.
He's ready to work.
PAUL KINLAN: So yeah,
so how are you?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah, good.
PAUL LEWIS: Good.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PAUL LEWIS: Yes, fantastic.
It was an opportunity to
hang out with you so--
ERIC BIDELMAN: Ah,
that's beautiful.
PAUL LEWIS: Well,
he humored me.
He couldn't turn it down.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Sorry I'm late.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
So we're just going--
ERIC BIDELMAN: Keep going.
ERIC BIDELMAN: It's up to me?
PAUL LEWIS: Yes, it is.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Want to talk
about the file system API?
PAUL KINLAN: We doing
file systems.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, yeah.
Just as a quick background, last
week, guys, in case you
didn't catch it, we talked
about the storage APIs--
chrome.storage.local and
chrome.storage.sync, which is
great if you're going to be
storing, say, app settings and
app states and things like that,
so small bits of data.
But when it comes to storing
blobs and bigger files, then
the fastest MAPI is your best
friend, and so we get Eric in
to talk about that.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's right.
That's where I come in.
PAUL KINLAN: Can you tell us
about your book, please?
We've already pimped it.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Oh really?
So I actually really enjoy-- the
HTML5 file system API is
what these guys are alluding to,
and also the Chrome file
system API that sort of
extends the W3C API.
But yeah, I got pretty excited
about it one day, and I
decided to write a book on it.
So if you are interested in
what we're talking about
today, go check that out.
I'm not going to plug it.
These guys have already
done that for me.
But if you want to share my
screen, we'll just start off
with a demo.
Do we have confirmation?
PAUL KINLAN: I don't know.
Did we get confirmation that
the screen is now shared?
ERIC BIDELMAN: I just want
to make sure people are--
yes.
ERIC BIDELMAN: We do.
We do have confirmation.
All right, so I built a quick
little Google Drive upload
client, a Chrome app that you
can sort of drag and drop
files on to, or you can upload
them to Google Docs.
And it uses both the Chrome file
system API and also the
W3C open-web API.
So let's give this a go.
I'm just going to click
my drive icon here.
So this is the app.
It's not that glorious
right now.
There we go.
So we just pulled in
some of my Google
Docs from Google Drive.
I've got the list here.
I can open these in Drive.
I can refresh this.
This is a frameless app, so I've
implemented my own close
button with some of the newer
stuff that you guys probably
covered without me there.
But we're missing one thing
here, and that is amazing
icons on this left
corner here.
So typically, you'd
have file icons.
For an audio file, you'd see a
little audio icon, or a text
file, you'd see a text icon.
So we don't have that here.
What's going on?
Well, of course, we can use
our friendly inspector.
And so if we actually pull up
the console, you see all of
these crazy console errors.
And this is our worst and best
friend at the same time--
CSP, the Content Security
Policy.
So you see what's happening is
I just requested all my docs
from Google Doc, and I'm pulling
them down, and I'm
trying to load these
image files.
So it's coming from some kind
of ssl.gstatic.com domain.
Not within our app, and
I'm getting these
not-seen origin areas.
PAUL KINLAN: Can you explain a
little bit why we have these
errors in place?
ERIC BIDELMAN: So CSP
is generally a great
thing for the web.
It's a great thing for apps.
It makes your app more secure.
It gives you some guarantees
about where information is
coming from.
And so it's basically
a security thing.
It's a great security feature.
And one thing that's on by
default is not being able to
just set an image source
tag or a video source.
You actually have to pull the
asset into your application
and import it somehow.
PAUL KINLAN: I think just to
come to one act a little bit
there, is this is actually a
relatively big change for web
developers, right?
Web developers normally expect
to be able to reference an
image source file, pull it
straight in, and you start
working with it.
And when you go through that
with generally native systems,
like iPhone and Android, is that
they're very much used to
actually downloading assets
inside the application and
dealing with them that way.
I think today we're going to
talk about why we're going to
do this and how developers
can.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, we've been
saying this for weeks, and
you'll hear us say it
over and over again.
Offline first.
It really is how these apps
need to be built.
You need to be thinking offline
first, and then how do
I get additional stuff
remotely, if needed.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's
a very good point.
CSP's there for security, but
it's also in place for trying
to make the app more offline.
So it should work
offline first.
And one way to do that is not
being able to reference an
image anywhere on the web you
have to actually bring it into
your application.
So this is the sample, the
Google Drive sample.
I'm not going to show you
all the code here.
But basically what I'm doing
is I'm making a request to
their Google Drive API, making
the feed request.
PAUL KINLAN: Can I just
ask one thing?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah.
Sure.
PAUL KINLAN: You always get this
question all the time.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Sure, sure.
PAUL KINLAN: What editor
are you using?
ERIC BIDELMAN: It's
a Sublime text.
Why do you ask?
It's my favorite editor.
It's fantastic.
I used to be a Textmate
fan, but Sublime--
PAUL LEWIS: Is sublime.
[LAUGHING]
PAUL LEWIS: No pun intended.
ERIC BIDELMAN: It's
a great editor.
It's got a lot of plug-ins you
can install for it, so I
highly recommend it if you're
doing any kind of front-end
development.
So here we are back in
the G Drive app.
And basically I'm just making
the AJAX request, right?
I'm using ANGLER JS,
so it's got some
nice little HTTP wrappers.
So I'm making it to the
main dockless feed.
And so here's the magic here
in the success call back.
So I pull down the entries from
the feed, and you can see
I've got this handy sort
of uncomment for CSP.
So right now what this tries to
do is, again, just send an
image source to that
gstatic URL we saw.
And since it's not of the origin
of my application, it's
going to fail.
It's going to fail CSP.
So instead what we're going to
do is we're going to make that
AJAX request to that
image file.
And then we're going to save it,
and we're going to create
a blob URL from that.
So essentially what we're
doing is making an AJAX
request, bringing in the image
to our application locally,
and then creating like a URL
handle to that image.
So then CSP hopefully should
work out for us.
So if you go back to the app,
refresh the app because I made
a code change, check
out our console.
So this time, boom.
We have fantastic little
glorious images and icons on
the left there.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, so in this
case, you were just getting
the blob from the XML you
requested and not even saving
it locally.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's right.
So in this case--
so this is a certain progression
here, Paul.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, that's cool.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah.
So we made an XHR.
You can see I have like 100 of
these icons that I've just
fetched, just using an
XML HTTP request.
And then I've used the
Create Object URL to
create a blob to this.
So if you actually right-click
these guys to inspect the
element in the inspector, you
can see that these image
sources are all blob URLs.
So they're not just referencing
the normal icon
file that I got from the feed,
but we actually created a
handle for those files.
So that's cool.
Now we have images.
We have icons.
We're fetching them.
PAUL LEWIS: But you said
you've got 100 of those
requests firing off, right?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Right.
PAUL LEWIS: So if somebody's off
the network or whatever--
PAUL KINLAN: Exactly.
PAUL LEWIS: They're still--
ERIC BIDELMAN: Right.
So if I switch Wi-Fi off, which
I'm not, but you're
absolutely right.
This won't work offline.
We'll get a bunch of
invalid images.
And if I refresh this, you can
see in my console, there's
another 100 of these
things being--
every time I give my new feed,
my new list of docs, it's
coming back with 100
image requests.
So that's not ideal.
It's not ideal for offline.
It's not ideal for
performance.
So what we can do is, I
implemented this amazing
success callback with file
system caching method.
So what this guy is going to
do is actually do the same
thing, so request all the images
using XHR, create blob
URLs from them.
But at the same time, it's going
to save those images
using the file system API.
So we're essentially just
caching all those icon files
and saving them for later.
And so the meat of that
looks like this.
We'll just make that XML
HTTP request as a blob.
So we'll pull down
all the images.
We'll get the blob, so it will
essentially get the image file
from the response, and we'll
write that image file out to
the file system API.
And so that write method
is up here.
It's pretty simple.
So this is boilerplate how
you'd use the HTML5 file
system API.
You essentially get this root
directory representing the
root of your application where
you can store files.
You give it a folder name.
I'll just call it Test Folder.
We'll create that folder if it
doesn't exist in our app.
And then we'll just essentially
loop through all
these and write each blob.
So we'll call it Get File.
It will create this
file for us.
If it doesn't exist, we'll
create a writer object, so
we're writing data to
this file entry.
You can set up event handlers
for errors or when the write
is complete.
We'll just call it
filewriter.write, and we'll
write that blob out.
So XHR to end the images, 100 of
those guys, and then write
each of them locally to
the file system URL--
or the file system
API, excuse me.
So I'm going to switch my
callback out to the amazing
one with caching and
give us a refresh.
All right.
So to the user, nothing
new is happening.
We got the images.
It's all working splendidly.
But what you see in my console
now is that we made the image
request, but we also wrote
100 files out to
the file system API.
So if I refresh this, hopefully
what you don't see
here in the console now is
100 XHRs and 100 writes.
So, indeed, we do have local
files, and we can again, verif
that a couple of ways.
We can go into the inspector.
And we can see that now these
image sources are set to file
system URIs instead
of blob URLs.
So these are being cached.
These are local to
our app now.
PAUL KINLAN: So I've
noticed you've got
your temporary storage?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Can you explain
a little bit
about temporary storage?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Sure.
So the file system API has
two storage modes.
One is the ability to store
temporary files.
It's great for caching.
In this case, we're
pulling an image.
We're caching them.
You're not guaranteed to have
data there when you fetch it
the second time.
So as space requirements and
space becomes an issue, Chrome
and the browser will kick that
out, so it will evict data.
Persistent storage is the other
type of storage, and
that's just what
it sounds like.
It's persistent.
And so you're guaranteed to
always have that data unless
the user or yourself
revokes it.
PAUL KINLAN: So how much
storage do you have?
So is temporary storage
flexible or is it--
ERIC BIDELMAN: So temporary
storage is a per-origin basis.
Well, with the Chrome APIs,
you can actually request
unlimited storage.
So using the unlimited storage
in the MAPIs file, that's a
great way to just say
my app can store
whatever it needs to.
There's no space requirements.
And then you can request as much
as you need, basically.
PAUL KINLAN: That's very cool.
Thank you.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah,
no problem.
And I want to point out
one last thing.
I'm using Canary for this,
and so I want to plug--
we just added file system API
support into the dev tools,
which is really cool.
PAUL KINLAN: Seriously?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah.
You guys probably noticed,
didn't you?
PAUL LEWIS: No, I
did not notice.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So under
Resource, this is my number
one requested feature for a
long time, because it's
actually really hard.
PAUL KINLAN: I can actually
swear this is a question on
the Q&A.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Is it?
Well, check another
one off the list.
But the hardest part is actually
knowing what's in the
file system.
And so by now having dev tools
support, this is just huge.
So if I click on this, I can see
that, yes, that folder I
created, that test folder--
apologies if this
is really small.
I open the test folder, and all
those images, all those
icons, have been cached and
stored in the file system.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
ERIC BIDELMAN: And
here's a pro tip.
The only reason I'm using a
folder here is just to be able
to delete it very quickly.
So I can come down here
into dev tools and
just nuke that folder.
PAUL KINLAN: Awww!
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah, and so if
I refresh it now, my app is
going to go through that whole
process of making XHRs,
pulling it back in, and now
they're re-cached again.
PAUL KINLAN: So one
question for you.
This doesn't necessarily relate
to the file system API.
When you did requests after this
blob, did you have to do
anything special to
the requests?
Because I've literally never
been able to get response or a
response-type blob
ever working.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Really?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That sounds
like a user error.
PAUL LEWIS: An error between
the chair and the
keyboard, my friend.
ERIC BIDELMAN: This little bit
right here is the only real
magic you need.
So normally, XHR pulls
text in, right?
And you have to do
crazy things like
base64 encode text.
Now you can set response type to
blob, and it just acts as a
binary file.
PAUL KINLAN: Nice.
So if I didn't pass that, I
would have to use a ray buffer
and then convert the ray buffer
to the other blob and--
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's true.
At some point, I think Chrome
only supported a ray buffer,
but we've changed that.
We added blob support.
So you don't have to go from a
ray buffer to blob and then
back and forth.
PAUL LEWIS: That sounds
a lot cleaner.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah.
It's a lot cleaner.
And obviously, the big use
case here is for caching
things that are not native to
your application and bringing
them in, whether it's video,
whether its images, whether
it's any type of static asset.
PAUL LEWIS: So earlier on, you
said that the Chrome Apps
version of this API is slightly
different to the W3C.
What are the main differences
that developers
need to be aware of?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Right.
Good call.
Before I do that, I just want to
plug-- if you're interested
in what we just showed there
with the file system writing
data, writing folders, check out
our "HTML5 Rocks" article
that I'm showing now.
That is all about the
W3C HTML5 API.
But what Chrome does
in particular--
and this is the documentation
page for it-- is extend the
capabilities of the
file system API.
So we have chrome.fileSystem,
which has a slew
of APIs under it.
The biggest thing is that unlike
the W3C API, you can
actually Save As, so
there's Save As
functionality in this API.
You can open a file and actually
write out t outside
the browser space.
So you can choose any file on
your hard drive and then read
and write to that file.
So it's sort of breaking out
of this browser security
model, the file system that
the HTML5 one has.
PAUL KINLAN: So the interesting
thing--
I think it's really interesting,
anyway--
ERIC BIDELMAN: I think it's
interesting, too.
PAUL LEWIS: I don't even know
where this is going.
PAUL KINLAN: I want to know
where this is going, because
[INAUDIBLE].
PAUL LEWIS: Huh?
No!
PAUL LEWIS: Really?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PAUL KINLAN: I'm allowed to
say the word Web Intents.
So you're shocked when you
bring up Web Intents in--
PAUL LEWIS: I'm trying
to get it in.
PAUL KINLAN: I've noticed.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL LEWIS: Generally
speaking, yes.
PAUL KINLAN: So the interesting
thing is that one
of the things with the Chrome
Apps effort is that in theory,
you show be able to find a
file on your file system,
right-click Open With, and then
find your web application
or your link to that there and
open that file inside your web
application.
We're not quite there
just yet.
But there's a series of command
line brackets, which I
can't remember off the top of my
head, where you can launch
your application with a
parameter which is the name to
a file on your page, like in
your file systems, like C:/,
like programfiles/images, or
whatever it is how they've
done Windows.
Specify the file, and then in
the unlaunched command,
there's a data element.
That data is the intent object,
and once you have a
reference to the file-- because
if it comes in as a
file object rather than a blob,
it's your app, you know
it's a file on the user
system, but you can't
write to it, right?
Properly?
You don't have the
permissions.
And the theory is, and it's what
we're still working on,
is that you get rightful file
entry for that intent object.
That converts it to something
that you can read and write
to, and then you can offer
the progressive save.
The way Web Intents works is
you'll send something out to
another application, edit
it, and then bring it
back into your app.
And that doesn't work so well
for any applications where you
want to write the document
and just keep saving it.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Autosave,
right?
That's a great use
case right there.
PAUL KINLAN: And that's exactly
the type of thing that
we're trying to do, is allow you
to launch your application
with Web Intents, but then
enhance the file system
capabilities with
the same thing.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Do you guys want
to-- should we just show
a quick demo of some of the
Chrome file system API actions
for reading and writing
a file out?
ERIC BIDELMAN: It doesn't use
Web Intents, but I think what
Paul's saying--
PAUL LEWIS: Aww.
PAUL KINLAN: You don't
want to see it.
ERIC BIDELMAN: One at a time.
PAUL LEWIS: Actually, the thing
you were saying about
the Open With, that'd be cool.
In the Q&A in previous weeks--
it's actually really good that
we are heading in
that direction.
So that answers that question
really well.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so if
we can see a demo.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah, there's
another demo in our project
page for the Chrome App samples,
and that's just this
basic app for file
system access.
And this is using the Chrome--
come on, page.
There we go.
And can we just make sure
we're sharing my screen.
So a basic demo.
It's essentially just
a file picker.
Nothing new here.
You can do this on
the web today.
But what I'm going to
do is select a file.
Let's see.
We'll do this awesome
web page.
So I just selected a web page.
I wrote it as a text file.
And this is using the
file of your API.
I've read that HTML file.
Here's all the HTML.
I can go ahead and edit this
file if I wanted to.
This is just an example of an
"HTML5 Rocks" article that I
have started and not finished.
Don't tell anybody.
But what we can do now that the
regular HTML5 file system
API can do is actually
save out this file.
We can save this anywhere on
our hard drive, which is
really cool.
So I think we'll implement
a Save As button.
I can call this debugging2.html
and save this
to my desktop.
And boom, when I do that, the
file's going to be saved.
And just to show you, I'm going
to reopen that file I
just saved out in this
application.
So debugging2 that we
just saved out.
And I didn't change
anything, but I--.
PAUL KINLAN: The path did.
ERIC BIDELMAN: The path did.
That's right.
So you can tell it's--
nice job.
Nice job, Paul.
PAUL KINLAN: Thank you.
Whew!
ERIC BIDELMAN: So we're
just writing a file.
We've opened a file for reading,
and we've also saved
a file to whatever
name we want.
And that's sort of just one of
many extensions that this--
PAUL KINLAN: So this is
on our GET repository?
ERIC BIDELMAN: This sample is
on our GET repository, yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
OK cool.
PAUL KINLAN: And is
your Google Drive
uploaded there as well?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah.
So those are both samples
in the repository.
PAUL KINLAN: OK.
So we should probably share them
after the program notes.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Sure.
And just as a caveat, what the
Google Drive example doesn't
have is the file system
stuff integrated.
So I'll actually check that in
later today and make sure the
caching works so you guys
can check that out.
PAUL LEWIS: When somebody comes
to uninstall the app,
what happens to the files
that they've thrown
into the file system?
Are they just removed?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Good question.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah.
Can I take this?
Step in?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RENATO MANGINI: Yes.
When you uninstall an app out
of the file system, the app
requested is totally removed.
When you install it back, if the
same app is request of the
file system, a new fresh file
system is assigned, too.
So there's no reuse of the send
box a file system area.
It's totally to your app while
it's installed, and when you
remove, it's done.
PAUL KINLAN: The theory is,
right, you could actually go
and find this directory inside
your file system, but you
can't easily read the files
because all the directory
names, everything's
confiscated.
So you can't actually discern
any of the information that's
been saved.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah, and
normally, it's usually
actually quite difficult
to know what's going
on under the hood.
PAUL KINLAN: And then to answer
the-- well, not to
answer the point,
because no one
actually asked the question.
But just to go full loop, I'll
say, wow, I can't believe I
even said that.
PAUL LEWIS: Well, you did.
PAUL KINLAN: I did.
PAUL LEWIS: And the internet
never forgets.
It's there on record,
my friend.
PAUL KINLAN: If you save
something to the desktop like
you did before, that's a
different type of thing.
But save it to your file system,
it will always be
there regardless of whether
your application has been
removed or not.
PAUL LEWIS: So the difference
is if you save the app with
the extended permissions,
then great.
Off you go.
It's not going to get removed
when you uninstall the app.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, and also,
just to kind of--
I think one final point.
I know the Chrome Apps team is
really interested in people's
feedback about how we can work
with images and data and pull
them in because it is a change
from what we do on the web.
Normally native app developers
are pretty used to this way.
You download the image, cache it
somewhere, and then display
inside the app.
It's a big change for web
developers and we want your
feedback to see if we can make
it as smooth as possible.
I don't know whether we'll see
the pure reference text done
on images from the back
end because we
can't control it, right?
That's the whole point, is that
if you're in control, we
can maybe provide a framework
like in the file just to go
off and start caching things,
make it a little bit easier.
ERIC BIDELMAN: I think some
kind of really interesting
super simple, easy-to-use
caching library on top a lot
of this new stuff, it would be
very trivial to write but very
helpful, I think,
for a lot of it.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
And you've already written the
API helper for file systems?
ERIC BIDELMAN: You plug me
before I plug myself.
PAUL KINLAN: So when I do the
Web Intents one, you've got to
pick me up like crazy, man.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Oh really?
OK.
I'm all over it, man.
But yeah, so I wrote this
library called filer.js that
Paul alluded to, and it's really
great if you want to
work with the file system
APIs in general.
It wraps everything
in LS and--
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, a
nice simple one.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah,
like a Unix-type
command for copy, move.
There's good stuff there.
And it sort of extracts a lot
of the asynchronous mumbo
jumbo that you have
to go through.
PAUL KINLAN: So, actuall, we
have a question that normally
people ask.
Is why are our APIs
asynchronous?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah, it's not
actually synchronous.
PAUL KINLAN: Can we just answer
that question now?
PAUL LEWIS: Let's do that.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Let's
take care of it.
Who wants to answer it?
PAUL KINLAN: Who wants
to answer it?
Oh, no.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PAUL KINLAN: So the Chrome team
are really keen on making
sure the browser and the whole
user experience never blocks.
And particularly when we're
dealing with data, you may
take this to the Chrome
storage API and not
particularly the file
system API.
We tell each other the user
experience never blocks
because the local storage
API has to block.
You know at that moment when you
save a key and it does a
whole lot of weird stuff where
it opens the entire data space
storage file behinds the scenes
and writes it back in
and pulls it back out.
With an asynchronous API, we can
make sure we're consistent
across tabs, across windows
applications, all
those types of things.
But also, we can provide an
experience that doesn't block.
And I think that's the
biggest one there.
ERIC BIDELMAN: For
this API, right?
We're talking about a ton of--
you saw me write a hundred
images out to-- we're doing
disk I/O, right?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
ERIC BIDELMAN: And that's the
last thing you want to do is
block your user experience
doing operations.
PAUL KINLAN: Especially
if you fling
the whole user interface.
You scroll down a
thousand items.
You don't want to have to fire
up all the requests and--
PAUL LEWIS: Arguably you could
be downloading a massive video
file as well, right?
And writing that might
take some time.
There's no guarantee that the
thing you're writing to is
going to be quick storage.
So--
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
PAUL LEWIS: --imagine writing
a big file to slow storage.
Your app just hangs.
Users get upset.
It's all bad.
PAUL KINLAN: When you look at JS
now, we see all these APIs
now pretty much async only.
We're trying to get
[INAUDIBLE]
on blocks, so developers,
especially JavaScript
developers, are starting
to get used to it.
So it's the mind shift from,
well, I had key value pair
originally, and it
was synchronous.
I just saved some data, and
it went and [INAUDIBLE].
And now [INAUDIBLE].
Maybe we can provide some apps,
like Backbone did when
we were doing some experiments
on Backbone.
Lawnchair, when Paul
was experimenting
with Lawnchair, right?
That is an inherently
asynchronous API.
PAUL LEWIS: One of the
challenges, I think, for the
[INAUDIBLE], if you have a
number of operations that you
need to complete and they're
going to happen
asynchronously, and you want to
coordinate an action when
several of those have
actually completed.
But that's the challenge.
I think it is a different
mindset that
you need to be in.
PAUL KINLAN: So I happened
to write a library.
PAUL LEWIS: Did you?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, I did.
PAUL LEWIS: That's funny.
PAUL KINLAN: It's almost
that you hear about it.
PAUL LEWIS: Goodness.
PAUL KINLAN: Observer, yes, it
was an experimental library,
but the idea is--
ERIC BIDELMAN: Is
it [INAUDIBLE]?
PAUL KINLAN: It's any normal
asynchronous callback.
What you basically say is, it
monitors changes on an object.
So if you have a callback which,
say, manipulates a JSON
object, which is not
[INAUDIBLE], it doesn't
particularly care about the
asynchronous API or the
geolocation API.
It just says, well, this
date when it's updated,
I'll watch for it.
And then when all these three
other different variables were
also updated, fire this
piece of logic.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So you basically
implemented Object
on Observe before it was time.
PAUL KINLAN: Maybe.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Does everybody
know what
Object on Observe is?
PAUL LEWIS: I do, but I would
love to hear you explain it.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Well, I searched
the web, and I'll
probably find interesting
links.
Object on Observe is the ability
to actually do exactly
what you're saying natively
in the browser.
So a lot of MVC frameworks,
for instance, use sort of
dirty checking to know what's
changed in an object and
update their data binding.
Instead, Object on Observe is
something that's being specced
out in the TC39--
PAUL KINLAN: [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
ERIC BIDELMAN: --record, but
it just as it appears.
But it's being specced out, and
it actually brings this
natively to the browser, so you
can instantiate an object
and know exactly what's changed
on it, what properties
have been added or removed.
So essentially, no more
dirty checking.
We can know this in an informant
way now, and so MVC
frameworks are going to
definitely benefit from this.
RENATO MANGINI: The Observer
is already
on the Canary, right?
ERIC BIDELMAN: It's not.
If you just do a search on
Object on Observe, there's
been a couple of great
posts already on it.
And there's a special build
of Chromium that has it
implemented that you can
start playing around.
There's a really fantastic
demo, too.
PAUL LEWIS: [INAUDIBLE].
RENATO MANGINI: I think there's
an implementation
already, because last week I
gave a talk, and I used the
Observer on my IO slides,
and it worked.
PAUL LEWIS: See, he's
a trailblazer.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Trailblazer.
RENATO MANGINI: I think
it just landed.
It's recent stuff.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
pretty cool.
PAUL LEWIS: So give
that a shot, see--
PAUL KINLAN: It's going to be
so cool for data binding.
PAUL LEWIS: It's going to be
cool in any number of ways.
When I wrote the 3D engine, one
of the biggest challenges
is when objects change.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PAUL LEWIS: That's all right.
Let's not go there.
But--
PAUL KINLAN: Do it.
RENATO MANGINI: Hey, do
you want to hear what
I did on this talk?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
RENATO MANGINI: I put some
of servers on the slides
themselves, and every time a
class changed, I called a
specific JavaScript function.
And this JavaScript function got
the slide color, the most
used color on the slide and
the central USB to DMX
lightning hardware.
So I changed the stage color,
background color, when I
switched it from one
slide to the other.
PAUL LEWIS: No way.
I So you actually were just
using the Chrome USB API to
make everything--
RENATO MANGINI: Yes.
PAUL LEWIS: --to organize
your presenting.
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah.
And it was available
for 1,000 people.
And it worked.
PAUL LEWIS: [INAUDIBLE].
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah.
I'm waiting for an
organization--
PAUL LEWIS: Is it out?
RENATO MANGINI: No, it's
not ready yet.
It will probably be later
of this week.
PAUL LEWIS: That's definitely
something
we're going to be showing.
PAUL KINLAN: So do realize
because we've got a hackathon
next week, it's an
internal one.
He can't actually
do that then.
If he comes on and shows
off his thing at the
end of the two days--
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah,
you're barred.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RENATO MANGINI: Absolutely,
absolutely.
We'll talk about that.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Just to clarify,
it sounds like you're
using mutation observers
and not Object on
Observe, which are--
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah,
yeah, true.
ERIC BIDELMAN: To clarify
for everyone.
RENATO MANGINI: That's true.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Actually,
observers are cool, too.
We should probably
do an amazing
session on that sometime.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, mutations
are like-- yeah.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah,
two different
things, but similar type.
You just watch for changes,
whether it's at the object
level or at the DOM level.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah.
True.
Sorry about that.
PAUL LEWIS: No problem, man.
Should we switch to
the Q&A then?
PAUL KINLAN: I think we should
go to the Q&A, see what kind
of questions people
are asking.
RENATO MANGINI: One
last thing.
Eric, can we discuss about the
use case from Chrome storage
and the file system API?
I'm a developer.
Why should I use Chrome
storage or file
system APIs and when?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Well,
everybody--
PAUL KINLAN: Quickly.
ERIC BIDELMAN: It's
way better.
Just like Web Intents is way
better for everybody.
No, I'm just kidding.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh!
Not Web Intents.
PAUL LEWIS: You guys.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So there's a
couple of different use cases.
You can start everything
in the file system API
if you wanted to.
But Chrome Storage has
the really great
ability to do syncing.
So there's sync that's
involved.
You don't, as a developer, have
to worry about syncing
data from your client and
keeping things across
different installs of
your application.
So that's one super anything
about Chrome Storage API.
The other thing is, if you need
a small amount of data,
there's no reason not to
use Chrome Storage.
It's great for that.
It's for small chunks of
data, very simple data.
Think of it as a syncable
solution
replacement for App Cat--
or excuse me, local storage.
PAUL KINLAN: App Cat, that
would be pretty cool.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That would
be really nice.
Whereas the file system API, if
you need more complex data.
If you need to store and create
folders, if you need to
store imagery and binary files
and blobs and videos and store
way more stuff than basic small
amount of data, that's
your best bet right there,
is the file system API.
RENATO MANGINI: That's
awesome.
PAUL KINLAN: So I think we
have a question about
synchronizing if you want to
save a file and synchronize it
across devices.
We don't have synchronized files
system API, which will
be absolutely killer.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That would
be really killer.
PAUL KINLAN: I think the--
we haven't exactly explored
this pattern
too much at the moment.
The general thought is to use
them from Drive potentially
using some of the API that
Eric used today.
Synchronize it through Drive.
And if you want to share a key
in the settings between your
two different apps, then you
share the basic what to pick
out back from Drive via the
Chrome sync storage mechanisms
essentially.
Whether it's tokens, with tokens
you can do that with
Google Drive, at least,
and then bring that
back in that way.
So it's non-sequenced, you have
to implement with Drive,
but then it also allows you to
do it with Dropbox and all
those other different APIs.
PAUL LEWIS: If this is a use
case that is of interest, we'd
love to get that feedback.
It's stuff that we can talk
through with the engineers,
and if that's the kind of things
that you app developers
want, then just let us know.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
ERIC BIDELMAN: It's
already the plan.
PAUL KINLAN: So onto
the questions.
Let me pick the nice
questions.
Paul.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: You are awesome.
PAUL LEWIS: Thank you.
PAUL KINLAN: No one said that.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Wait a minute.
That was downloaded, man.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL LEWIS: That was
inappropriate.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: Apologies.
Let me refresh in two seconds.
The first question that would
be the most popular one is
when will it be possible to
upload new packaged apps
manifest v2 from the
Chrome Store?
We don't particularly have an
answer to that right now.
The thing is, right now at the
moment, it's still only
available in Canary and Dev.
Some of them might have
gone to [INAUDIBLE].
I'm not too sure.
You want to make sure the
framework is in a lot better
state than the development
experimental phase that we're
in at the moment.
So we don't have an answer right
now, but we will tell
you as soon as it's going to
happen, and we'll talk you
through the whole process
of uploading and
everything like this.
That doesn't mean you can't make
applications and get them
installed and everything,
but it's a
little bit more complex.
You have to load them in through
the load extensions
menu and that kind of stuff.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So it's not
production-ready just yet.
We need a lot of feedback.
Obviously, this is why we're
doing all these talks at the
moment to kind of get this.
My question back to you, Jarek?
Harek?
PAUL LEWIS: I think
it's Yarek.
PAUL KINLAN: Yarek?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, I believe he's
from Poland, so Yarek.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, Yarek.
Sorry, I apologize if
I got that wrong.
Just send us things that you
want that the Chrome App Store
to be able to do for you
as well as far as
the Chrome Apps packaged--
Version 2 packaged app
end point as well.
Because if there's things that
frustrate you now, we want to
get those things fixed in the
next versions at least.
That was kind of diplomatic,
wasn't it?
It's kind of cool.
Next question.
Why Chrome Storage [INAUDIBLE]
is so small?
Right now, it's set to 4K.
It's not enough if you want to
store user-defined keyword
shortcuts in a medium-sized
app.
So I believe this is per item.
PAUL LEWIS: Per item.
So you could store--
each key would--
PAUL KINLAN: Each key
is a separate item.
PAUL LEWIS: So 4K for a single
keyboard shortcut would be
quite a lot.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So I think it's just the way you
structure your app, right?
Basically, break it out
into different keys
with different bindings.
If you have something where you
can't discover those keys,
because it might be just like
a complete custom space, is
have a mapping object
to say what types of
keys are inside there.
But you should be able to get
most of it done inside 4K.
PAUL LEWIS: The key to this
is to understand that
chrome.storage.sync--
PAUL KINLAN: [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL LEWIS: It wasn't, but it
can be now that you've asked.
PAUL LEWIS: Is to remember that
we're not aiming for a
storage solution here that is
storing these big chunks of
data all in one go.
We need to break these things
down into smaller--
I want to say bit-sized chunks,
but that's not right.
You just break it down.
And like you said, it's about
structuring your app and
working with those quotas for
that app because it allows us
to sync better, basically.
PAUL KINLAN:Yeah, I mean, the
more feedback that we get--
PAUL LEWIS: But if--
yeah, if it's a--
PAUL KINLAN: If every single
developer says that--
PAUL LEWIS: Right.
You want that, then
let us know.
PAUL KINLAN: Could you explain
the phone source sync
[INAUDIBLE]?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
So there's a difference between
the quotes, which are
just the amount that you can
write, and then this is about
how often you can write
that stuff.
So again, this is stopping
you from flooding loads
of data to the API.
PAUL KINLAN: If it's applied
between, in theory, you could
change it--
PAUL LEWIS: OK.
PAUL KINLAN: --you'd
probably presume.
But why you'd want to because
all the users wouldn't have
that flag, unfortunately.
I think it's more--
ERIC BIDELMAN: I have a
question for you guys.
PAUL KINLAN: OK.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Is there a way to
explicitly say want my app
to start synchronizing?
Like you store a bunch
of stuff, and it just
queues it up, right?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
The way it kind of works
is [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC BIDELMAN: So Chrome
the browser just
handles that, right?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, it works
it out for you.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Cool.
PAUL LEWIS: It's supposed to
be seamless for you, as a
developer, to not have to get
your hands dirty with
[INAUDIBLE].
ERIC BIDELMAN: Syncing
is our problem.
The less you have to do,
the better, for sure.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
And actually this leads on
to another question.
Let's say I have accidentally
exceeded the maximum number of
write operations per hour.
Does that mean that from now on,
data that I write to the
Chrome Storage sync
is ignored?
Or will it be kept in local
storage and synced later?
That's a really good question,
which I don't actually know
the answer to.
And we'll speak to the
engineering team today, and
we'll post a response
to that question.
I think that's the easiest
thing to say.
Because I could tell you
something, and it would
probably end up being
completely wrong.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, there are only
two options, but it would
probably be the wrong
one, right?
PAUL KINLAN: Next question is
how can an automated deploy
script interact with the Chrome
Store to upload an
updated extension?
If this is not currently
supported, when
can we expect it?
It's not currently supported
and I don't know when
we can expect it.
[INAUDIBLE].
PAUL LEWIS: OK.
PAUL KINLAN: So it's
kind of awkward.
I spoke to quite a few
developers who, as part of
their build script, they want it
to alter that so it will be
automatically updated.
Because from the Chrome
App Store, it's manual
intervention essentially.
And you should be able
to get around it, but
right now you can't.
So it's a manual
operation only.
Again, this is great feedback
just to send back to the team.
RENATO MANGINI: Can
I ask Chris to
submit a bug on crbug.com?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
You can.
RENATO MANGINI: So
please, Chris.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Chris, if you're
out there, bro, can you
submit a new.crbug.com?
PAUL LEWIS: That
would be great.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
We'll track it from there.
And you can email me,
PaulKinlan@google.com, so I
can star it and then refer
it to the correct teams.
So yes.
So--
oh, right.
Here we go.
Do you have any plans of
exposing the chrome.storage
API in dev tools as it's already
in the local storage
and indexed DB?
And this is Yarek again.
We didn't mention that
the file system API.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: In there we
haven't got Chrome
Storage, have we?
ERIC BIDELMAN: We don't.
I think dev tools support is
one of these things-- it's
sort of a chicken-and-egg
problem, at least with the
file system API.
Without the ability to debug,
you sort of lose the ability
to really recover an app really
quickly and learn
what's going on.
Same thing with indexed DB.
The sooner, the better as far
as dev tools support.
Storage APIs for Chrome, it's
going to be one of these
things that the dev tools team
needs to prioritize.
But they're always looking for
new stuff to implement, so if
you think this is super
important, I think we should
file a bug for this, too.
PAUL LEWIS: I was going to say,
yeah, anything like this,
where you're--
ERIC BIDELMAN: So
that you're up.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, throw it
straight into [INAUDIBLE]
and let us know, and we will
start chasing that.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so the Chrome
team will work on the
start issues and all
the other things.
PAUL LEWIS: It's a good
pro tip, actually.
Don't put "me, too"
in the comments.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
PAUL LEWIS: Star it.
That's the best way
to let the--
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, me,
too, is bad grammar.
It's me also.
PAUL LEWIS: Aside from the
linguistic issue there, let's
say it's more helpful to the
engineering team to see stars.
They all like stars.
PAUL KINLAN: So a new a new
question in from Eli Grant.
Is the type Save File
UI coming to a
anchor download attribute?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Good.
That's a great question.
So as far as I know, this is a
big feature request on the web
today, is being able
to do that Save As.
You save out a file that you've
created in JavaScript
or something.
And unfortunately, I don't
think anybody has a good
answer to this right now.
All the mailings are
working groups.
As soon as you open up the
user's hard drive to reading
and writing data and anything
outside the browser, sandbox,
it's a whole security issue.
So I would say not any time soon
as far as I can tell, but
this is why the Chrome Apps APIs
have expanded on the W3C
HTML5 API to do more.
We have the permission
model, the manifests.
You can have some guarantees
there as far
as security is concerned.
But this is something,
obviously, we hope to bring to
the open web.
Any web app can use those
set Save As for now.
PAUL KINLAN: So I'm going to
mention Web Intents again.
Is that something in the future
we hope that files will
be able to be opened
with Web Intents?
To download?
ERIC BIDELMAN: That
would be cool.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, we do have
an RS feed in [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL LEWIS: You should
make that happen.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
[INAUDIBLE].
PAUL LEWIS: Well, you did
prioritize the anchor so far.
Really?
ERIC BIDELMAN: So just to point
out that the download
attributes are actually
really powerful.
With an attribute,
you can download
and name a file anything.
The only thing that it doesn't
have going for it is the
ability to save it wherever
you want and--
PAUL KINLAN: I think that's
where the question is going.
It's saying can I open
[INAUDIBLE].
ERIC BIDELMAN: Exactly.
So you can't read and write
to My Pictures folder.
It'll just go in the browser's
generic download folder.
But we're one step closer.
PAUL KINLAN: We don't have
enough time for many more
questions, unfortunately.
We can do two more, though.
I am a staff of University of
Nigeria, and our university
web site is there.
It has an email link.
Am I qualified to attend
this show?
Yes.
PAUL LEWIS: Everyone's
qualified.
PAUL KINLAN: Everyone's
We don't know whether we're
available with future live
stream instance in Nigeria,
but the videos should be
available worldwide after
they're recorded.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: If you'd
like to watch.
And then we'll seen one of the
last questions, which is
really cool.
I did see a question come in and
pop up a second ago, which
I thought was really
interesting.
Just a general question.
Which kind of model patterns
do you use when you're
developing in JavaScript?
And what do you think about
things like RequireJS,
CommonJS and the async module
definition, et cetera?
It's a long question.
I don't know whether we've
got an amazing amount of
time to answer it.
I think we need to build the
structure of our apps a lot
better than we do
at the moment.
It's an absolute pain
and a nightmare.
Whether the actual--
it's still the build time.
You structure your application
with modules when you build it
and compile it, but then it's
all compiled into one min.js
file when you're ready
for deployment.
PAUL LEWIS: The whole min.js
file thing is really--
I wouldn't say it's bad
practice, because it's really
good practice for the
drive-by web.
It's not that it's less of an
issue with that, but the thing
that comes in here is that
if you minify all the
JavaScripts, yeah, you're
delivering a smaller file.
But it's not the same thing as
reducing the number of request
for the drive-by web, which
is a really cool thing.
PAUL KINLAN: We need to do
tests, actually, to see.
Because we don't know, even
though it's on the file system
and stored locally, when they
are loaded in 10,000 is much
different from loading one in.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
So I think it bears some
investigation as to what the
right pattern is for allowing
developers to write the
best-possible app.
PAUL KINLAN: I just
generally think--
I want to ponder on this
question a little bit.
The great thing about web
application development and
site development, app
development for JavaScript, is
that we've got a lot of
different libraries which you
can use for reference
right now.
I don't have any preference
between the RequireJS and
CommonJS instance.
PAUL LEWIS: What I would say in
the context of CSP for some
of these libraries is it's worth
bearing in mind that not
all the functionality--
say, for example, an MVC
framework, if you're used to
using that, It may be that it
does some things with EVAL or
new function or rooting or
things like this that under
CSP rules aren't allowed.
So you may find that some of the
things you're trying to do
on a day-to-day basis have to be
adjusted in the context of
Chrome Apps.
But there is some guidance,
and we're going to be
expanding on that over the three
weeks to do with MVC
frameworks specifically
for Chrome Apps.
And we're going through the
commonly used frameworks, and
we're documenting what's
different, what you might need
to adjust, and those
kinds of things.
PAUL KINLAN: And I think an
important point as well, is if
you've used CommonJS or
RequireJS and it doesn't work
in Chrome platform apps,
please let us know.
File a bug on [INAUDIBLE].
Email us as well, because we
want to make sure that all the
development tools that web
developers are used to in
building these applications
will work from day one,
essentially.
If they don't, then we have to
make a good decision why we're
not going to fix it.
Or just try and fit it, that's
the easier thing.
ERIC BIDELMAN: This is kind of
forward-thinking, but I'm also
really excited about
ES6 modules.
So a lot of this module loading
that you're doing in
frameworks that require Common,
you're going to be
able to do it natively
in JavaScript soon.
So that's going to
be really cool.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: [INAUDIBLE]
working with some of those?
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah, he's has
been checking it out and doing
some investigations there.
But very forward-thinking, but
it's still important to get
excited about it.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
I think we're done.
I think we answered
all the questions.
ERIC BIDELMAN: We're done?
That was fun.
PAUL KINLAN: It was good.
It was great to have you here.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Hey, sorry
I'm late, guys.
PAUL KINLAN: Thank you for
coming to Mountain View all
the way from Mountain View.
We'll make this trip regularly
for you to come
out just to do this.
ERIC BIDELMAN: All
right, all right.
PAUL LEWIS: I was thinking about
him coming to London.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: [INAUDIBLE]?
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: Anyway,
I'm diverging
from this whole thing.
I'm trying to close this
whole thing out.
Thank you very much
for watching.
If you have any questions, get
them on [INAUDIBLE], or email
me, Paulkinlan@google.com.
Email the lists that
we have as well.
Please let us know.
And we'll see you next week with
the topic which is TBA.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes, we will
be putting out the--
PAUL KINLAN: [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
stuff.
So look out for that,
and let us know
what you want us cover.
PAUL KINLAN: Thank
you very much.
Bye.
PAUL LEWIS: Bye.